which are the acts which are allowed
during
EA the acts which are permitted during
EA that if a need
arises a person can go out of the mosque
as mentioned earlier either relieve
himself or to wash or to GLE or to do wo
or if there's no food Etc as the
Hadith with wife of the prophet he says
Inari number three in the book OFA
Hadith number 2029 that the prophet
while doinga never entered the house
unless there was a
need the things which are otherwise
permitted duringa is a person can eat
and drink and
sleep in the mosque he can eat and drink
and sleep in the mosque but he should be
careful that he should maintain the
sanctity and maintain the cleanliness of
the mosque because it's a place of
worship a person can even comb the hair
he can oil his hair he can remove the
unwanted hair from the body he can cut
his nails he can do woodoo he can wash
he can have a bath he can wear new
clothes he can put perfume these things
are bitted as it's mentioned in the
Hadith of sari volume number three in
the book of Hadith number
2028 that a pleas with her she says that
while doing the prophet from the mosque
he put the head into the house and
though she was during a menual cycle she
combed the hair of the prophet and put
oil in the head it's also mentioned in
the next Hadith ofari Vol number three
in the book of number
2029 she says that while doing E when
the prophet is in the mosque he used to
put his head into the house and she used
to comb the hair and oil the hair and
the Prophet never used to enter the
house unless there was a need so it
means that you can comb the hair you can
oil the hair and the other things which
I
mentioned further it's also allowed to
pitch a tent in the mosque or in the
backyard of the
mosque it's mentioned
inkari Vol number three in the book of
Hadith number
2034 she says that the prophet used to
do for the last 10 days of Ramadan
and she used to pitch a tent for him and
after offering F Salah he used to come
at the place of and enter the
tent is mentioned in say Muslim Mar
number two in the book of fasting Hadith
number
2641 the prophet Dida in the last 10
days of Ramadan and after offering F
Salah he came at the place OFA and
ordered a tent to be pitched and a tent
was pitched where doing further it's
also allowed for your wife to come and
talk to
you and speak to you while doinga she
can enter the mosque and it's mentioned
in s
bukari volume number three in the book
of Hadith number
2035 that safia M pleas with her was the
wife of the Prophet while the prophet
doing she entered the MOs and she came
and she spoke to him and after a while
when she was leaving the prophet
accompanied her to the gate of the
mosque the Gate of um Salma and two
ansar men they entered the
mosque and they wish the prophet salams
and then the prophet said that don't run
away she is my wife saf
H so the two said Subhan Allah oh Allah
that means how could we think such a
thing and they felt a bit hurt and how
could the prophet think that we are
doubting the prophet so then the prophet
replies and it says that the Satan runs
in the body and can reach any part of
the body like the blood can reach any
part of the body and I was afraid lest
some evil thought may come into your
mind that the reason I clarified that
she's my wife so that gives us a
guidance
that when we are in public and someone
doubts have to clarify and even the
prophet did that alhamdulillah so we
come to know that the Vives of the
personing can enter the mosque and
further it's mentioned in s bukari
volume number three in the book of
Hadith number
that she says that one of the wives of
the Prophet did with the
prophet and further it's mentioned
inkari number three in the book of
Hadith number 2026 the prophet used to
do in the mosque for the last 10 days of
Ramadan and after he expired his wife
continued with the practice so during e
also allowed to speak to the wife and
spend time with her for your answer